so in this video I'm going to talk about
RNA interference or RNAi AI and also si
are animated knockdowns so RNA AI is a
phenomenon of gene silencing in mRNA
level so if we have a particular gene
and we want to silence that gene in an
mRNA level such that the mRNA of that
particular gene doesn't express into
protein then we would perform RNAi I
experiment and in our research RNA I or
si are animated knockdown is very
important particularly if we want to
know about the role of a protein inside
a cell and let's say the role of the
protein is not characterized it then
what we can do we can actually knock
down that particular protein inside our
cultured cell and let's see
without that protein what happens inside
the cell what changes happens inside the
cell in morphology in terms of
survivability what change happens inside
the cell we can also judge so the basic
concept behind RNA interference is we
have a knockdown construct we have an
interference construct and that
construct is basically a portion of the
cDNA of a particular protein that we
want to knock downs let's say we want to
knock down a protein X so the cDNA for
protein X so the cDNA a portion of the
cDNA of protein X would be cloned in
this particular orientation followed by
a linker or a spacer and then again the
cDNA of that same particular protein X
would be cloned in a opposite
orientation now when and this whole
construct known as RNA I construct would
be actually delivered into the cell by a
liposome so you can see here the whole
construct is actually covered by a
liposome and it is fused in the cultured
cell so when we treat the cultured cell
with this liposome in and inside the
liposome we have these knockdown
construct it
get inside so in step number two we can
see that in the step number two in step
number two the liposome fuses with the
cell membrane and gets inside so inside
we have our knockdown construct and from
a knockdown construct it would be
produced it would convert it into our
double-stranded RNA it would produce a
double-stranded RNA a hairpin RNA and
endogenous molecule known as dizer which
is actually a member of the family rnase
tree which is a 200 kilo dalton
multi-domain protein actually it would
cleave these two strands of the hairpin
RNA and would separate them and after
separation it would produce two strands
one is guide on his guide strand another
is passenger strand and another is
passenger strand the passenger strand
would be degraded but the guide stand
would be important for the further steps
now the guide stabbed strand gets
associated with a large protein complex
known as risk RNA i silencing complex so
now the guide strand get associated with
the risk and side-by-side what is
happening inside the cell that from our
genome from our chromosomes
transcription of that particular protein
X of protein X is happening so the gene
for protein X is actually making the
mRNA for protein X and let step this
mRNA would be converted into protein X
by translation now we want to silence
these mRNA of that protein X in this
mRNA level now what we have we have our
knockdown construct against these
protein X and if we get back to our
concept so our guide strand is
associated with risk now the guide
strand along with the risk is now
going towards this protein X and it
would be associated with protein X mRNA
along with many other proteins many many
helper proteins and some Argonaut
proteins and what it will do it would
chop up the complex of endogenous mRNA
and this guide mRNA so ultimate fate is
the destruction of the endogenous mRNA
so the protein X mRNA is actually
destroyed
so no more protein X could be formed
from this mRNA so we would say we would
we actually knocked protein X down
inside this cell so this is this is how
actually in a cultured cell we can knock
down particular proteins and see in
absence of those proteins what change
actually happens so this is how the the
whole system works the most important
players are Dicer which would produce
the guide strand and guide strand would
would be actually complementary against
that particular endogenous mRNA and the
guide strand along with risk would bind
to that protein X mRNA and it would
degrade the mRNA so the key points that
we should remember that the da's RNA is
processed into small interfering RNA so
here you can see this is the TS RNA it
would be processed into guide strand and
this guide strand would do the rest dip
and die cell would actually chop these
two strands and it would create the
guide strand and die so is actually 200
kilo dalton multi-domain
enzyme of RNAs 3 family so it can cleave
double-stranded RNA into single-stranded
RNA and risk contains many other
proteins such as Argonaut proteins and
risk is actually RNA i induced a
silencing complex and it would chop the
mRNA off and ultimately the expression
from that particular mrna would be
blocked ok so that's all about RNA
interference and RNA i mediated
knockdown hope you enjoyed the video
please
like and subscribe